in britain lawmakers are offering
prayers this morning in memory of their
longtime colleague who was stabbed to
death on friday they paid tribute at the
church where parliament member david
amos was meeting with constituents at
the time of the attack authorities are
now calling his murder an act of
terrorism roxanna saberi has more now
from london roxanna good morning
good morning michelle police here in
london said overnight the killing was
potentially motivated by what they call
islamist extremism in their custody as a
25-year-old british man they arrested at
the scene of the murder
paying tribute the morning after the
murder prime minister boris johnson laid
flowers for one of britain's longest
serving lawmakers
he was inside this church just east of
london yesterday that david amos was
stabbed multiple times while meeting
with his constituents
police say he died at the scene where
they arrested a 25-year-old suspect who
they believe acted alone
well my right honourable friend the
69-year-old conservative member of
parliament was known for his hard-line
views on brexit and for campaigning for
animal welfare his murder has stunned
his community
and britain's political establishment
and the one thing we do know
nothing will stop democracy nothing will
stop us carrying out our duties but it's
also sparking calls for tighter security
just over five years ago labor mp joe
cox was shot and stabbed by a far-right
extremist while also meeting with
constituents her sister kim ledbetter
became an mp this year
it's really important that we get good
people in public life
but
this is the risk that we're all taking
you know and so many mps today will be
scared by this
authorities here now plan to review
lawmakers security mps get police
protection while in parliament but
typically travel without it when they go
home to meet with voters jeff
what a frightening story roxanna thank
you